let's talk about the most important
thing to start this interview off right
right at the get-go the tyler stout
alamo poster that is behind you by the
mondo
tyler stefano yeah i'm a big fan of
tyler's work
how'd you get that poster i got that
poster when
um but numberthon i think it was uh
2005 uh when hustle and flow played
no excuse me excuse me i'm going back
2007
when black snake moan played at button
that's right
got it i i'm a big fan i'm a big fan of
tyler people aren't familiar
look up tyler stout uh he's a really
good art and that's oh yeah
he's he's all his posters are incredible
i've always wanted one
of black snake mode i felt like he would
be able to to
to get that sweaty lusty
look better than anybody i i definitely
think that you should talk to
tyler i will i'll send him this this
interview i'll i'll message it
um let's jump into so i've been everyone
i've been talking to i asked the same
first two questions
which is for you uh what tv series would
you love to guest
direct i can't pick like you know like
manimal or anything like that i gotta
like pick something
you can pick manimal that completely
works
i definitely just recently got into
search party and that's
that's a lot of that's a lot of fun um
i would like to do anything in the
battlestar galactica world
i i i wish there was a way to do
battlestar galactica totally retro like
like you just
as if it was done in the 70s but i would
probably
frizzetta it up a little bit more i'd
probably just go ahead like you know
those those great pictures that frazetta
made
of battlestar galactica that would be in
tv guide i don't know if you know what
i'm talking about i
believe i would probably just goose up
the
barbarellaness of it a little bit more
that's that's that's my answer
i would like to see that um
i am curious what was it like watching
um
three six mafia win the oscar and what
kind of party happened after
um that's very interesting that you say
that because i remember the party well
first of all it was
completely surreal um because we just
really
thought that after you know after we
made hustle and flow that
it would probably just go to like
walmart like a dvd release we did not
know that
we would eventually have like two oscar
nominations and then much less my my
my buddies from here in memphis
tennessee winning
you know uh an oscar um that night
um i remember i was um
i was uh driving home from the oscars
and my agent called me
and said prince would
like you to come to his party
and i got driven up to
prince's house uh and and i'll never
forget a van took me up
to a long purple uh carpet that took me
into
this uh into this mansion and
no one is there it's just me and
ludacris
and we're kind of like you know wendy
and lisa walked by and then prince
walked by and we're like hey hey
and like chris and i are like what's
going on man like we the only people
here
and then this is sounding so like i'm
just name dropping everything but it was
this kind of an evening then chris rock
comes down in an elevator
and it opens up and he's like what are
you all doing down here and so
then ludacris and i we follow chris rock
up this elevator
and the doors open to the rooftop and
everyone is there
like there was a river of chocolate um
sheila e
was getting ready to to perform
everybody that was somebody was there
and i'll never forget i was staying
there and i had nowhere to sit and i
hear
yo memphis and i look over and there's
morgan freeman
and he goes i gotta take care of this
memphis boy scoot over and he's gonna so
i watched sheila e next to
morgan freeman uh uh at prince's house
uh the party afterwards so that's that's
my uh that's my party story
that's all the party story that i'm
gonna tell you about
first of all that's amazing and second
of all
that's a night you will never forget for
the rest of your life no
no no never never um i have so many
things in 10 minutes so let me jump into
um what after dolomite
uh which is universally like everyone
loves loved
dolomite and i'm just curious what did
you all of a sudden do like a lot of
meetings after that film was it all of a
sudden
you know what i mean like when you when
you do like a hot movie like that
no no you know because uh there was some
uh
i you know there's projects that i'd
already kind of like been cooking with
that that i'm i'm still
cooking with but then it was so quickly
that we went into coming to america
um i think that the love that happened
with with dolomite
is uh what was just so
i'm not saying i didn't get plenty of
love i know i did but so much of it was
just like oh thank you eddie's back like
we we get
we get eddie murphy in this really great
movie you know
and uh and so a lot of people were just
very curious about our process
it's like well that you know whatever
worked between you guys is obviously
working
and um i think eddie felt the same way i
know i did
um and that's that's why we we just so
quickly went into coming to america i
mean i think that
i i got told about the gig as a matter
of fact this would be interesting for
you like
i was at a screening of dolomite an
early screening
like like we had not wrapped the cut
and i had invited all the writers from
empire
that i was working on to come over and
watch it and then i invited john
singleton
rest to seoul and he came over and we
watched dolomite but but right before
dole might happened uh eddie and arsenio
walked in
and so to see everybody just their eyes
go wide like and i could see eddie and
arsenio sitting in the front row but i
could see all the
the writers behind them just going oh
man you know
and and and that night uh eddie asked me
if i'd be interested in doing coming to
america
too and so i think i think at the
premiere at toronto
for for dolomite as my name
we were already three weeks into
shooting coming to america so it really
was my first ever back-to-back
movie just having to have eddie murphy
in it you made this movie for paramount
and i definitely think that having it
come out on amazon is going to have it
seen by
so many more people you know that
opening weekend but i am curious about
the rating
because obviously you made it for pg-13
do you think if you had made it for
amazon
it would have been an r rating or how
did that rating sort of come about
it wouldn't have look i know that you
know
i follow you on twitter i know i i know
i know what's happening out there in the
world where
where people are like oh my god did i
just see that coming to america
is pg-13 but it's not like some
cash grab or something like that where i
think paramount wanted it to be more
like we really
were having these conversations about
where coming to america
exists with people you know and
if you look at the original coming to
america other than the bathers and other
than like really hearing like the f word
a lot
it's it's not really a crude
movie it's it's an eddie eddie every day
would say like
just remember and he's he's really like
i mean
this was like important he was like
coming to america
is different from all the other movies
that i've made it's a fairy tale
people are having fun rooting for
akin you know they're not necessarily
there
for anything especially crude you know
it is not delirious it's
it's not raw it occupies a different
place in his
in his movies you know and so
when we started um but when we made the
film we would
do jokes that pushed it and we did not
care about rating
then we started like showing it to
audiences and what we found
was even the core audience people that
are my age that like remember the first
movie
they responded more to uh other jokes it
wasn't like suddenly like we were like
oh it's gotta be pg-13
but now when i showed it to eddie i
remember the first time that like we
showed him the cut
he called me up and he was like i'm i'm
actually really proud
that like i don't say the n word in this
movie anywhere like it's
it's a it's a african-american cast and
and everybody can watch it just like the
original movie like the globe embraced
it so there wasn't like
if i went to amazon suddenly i was gonna
have like
you know 20 naked bathers in the movie
it it just didn't seem like it felt like
that was the movie we were making
because
so much of what this movie's tone was
about as well
was that a team is a parent you know i
saw this when i was a teenager and i now
have
teenagers and it's kind of about coming
to terms with the fact that you've maybe
lost some of your idealism and you got
to start listening to your kids
and as many as much as people would
think like oh well that's such a lofty
take on coming to america it's like yeah
but not not
really like you're still in the first
movie dealing with an identity as to
like well what is akeem going to be
versus what
his father wants him to be and i you
know
really the move to amazon you know
though tricky for me because i really
wanted it to be in a theater
you know with people like laughing just
because of the world the way it is now i
just feel like it's a perfect
time and gift for the movie to come out
so people get together with their
families and watch coming to america and
then watch coming to america you know
and
and have a fun fun week with that i
don't want to give away anything in case
i run this before the movie comes out
but there's
uh an easter egg or two to there's
definitely an easter egg to a different
eddie murphy movie
um in this which i loved
and but i'm just curious for for can you
sort of talk about the easter eggs that
are in the movie i don't want to give
them all away you know what i mean
um yeah there there's there's plenty i
mean i i
i would say that what's great about
those easter eggs is that you know we
definitely lean into the
nostalgia when it's appropriate um
there's times that i felt like
my job on in the production team was
like so many people would come up to me
and say well what about this from the
first one what about this
and be like uh we can maybe use that
that may be too obscure
um but but fans of the original are
going to watch this
and realize that we are definitely
tipping our hat to landis and
and and also to you know to elements in
the first movie
um you know not to give away any any
easter eggs that you're trying to hide
but like
yeah i mean we had to reference the duke
brothers in this
in this movie they referenced the duke
brothers in the first movie
i personally you heard it here think
that that would be a fantastic
movie uh you know i don't know if it's
like gotta be coming to america three
or it's trading places too but to see um
eddie from uh trading places and coming
to america having to be in a movie
together dealing with duke brothers
i don't know i think that'd be a great i
think that'd be a fun mashup to see but
uh
you know there's there's um there's some
things that i even was thinking like oh
should we utilize this meaning like um
like even king joffre's crown you know
you you look at that crown and maybe
back in the day it looked good but today
it looks like it's kind of made out of
lucky charms you know it's got like all
these like off-center jewels you know
that kind of look like the marshmallows
and
and lucky charms but you hold it in your
hands and you look at it and you
immediately get this feeling like ah
this is this is the crown of king jaffe
jober
you know so you would need to have those
elements in the movie even though
ruth carter academy award winner is like
doing these amazingly modern uh
gorgeous uh costumes did you have a much
longer cut did you have a lot of deleted
scenes
uh yeah we did have a few deleted scenes
but not not especially you know nothing
uh uh there there may have been a longer
cut that
maybe allowed some of the music numbers
that i enjoyed so much making in here
uh go a little bit longer um but uh
uh no no not not a tremendous amount but
uh
maybe maybe they'll i think we have a
few that may be coming out
if i'm if i could be mistaken but uh
obviously people in the first movie love
soul glow you know it's a whole
thing um and i know there's a poster in
this movie
um on a wall for soul glow was it was it
ever going to be like a bigger part of
the sequel i'm just curious it's just
you know it it wasn't and and what i
felt that we could do i mean i think
that there was a draft once where like
there was a soul glow commercial on tv
and we accounted for that when we filmed
but in the
in the in the mix of the movie it just
kind of felt a little bit out of place
you know it almost felt like we were
showing it for the fact that we were
just
that we could show it but it wasn't
necessarily like moving the movie
forward so what i love about how amazon
is now
selling this movie is that now soul glow
is going to be like its own thing you
know so is sexual chocolate
you know you'll be hearing some things
in the next couple of days of like
little
little like trailers and movies that we
can
we can use the whole iconography of
coming to america
at you know outside of the movie as well
you know and so we've
still been doing some creative things
with soul glow even though there's not
like a specific plot point with it
congrats on everything um thank you so
much and um you know i wish you nothing
but the best